[Music]
[Applause]
whoa oh my goodness happy Monday happy
Rosh Hashanah Shana Tova to all you
celebrate out there and welcome back to
the break room this is our daily live
show that keeps you updated on all the
nerdy fandom news you need to know right
here live from our very own break room
coming up on the show today James Earl
Jones says no more Vader doing the voice
that's pretty good we got there we got
there hey and we're gonna talk about
andor's body count his body count yes
yes and werewolf By Night ain't the
scariest thing hitting the DC MCU oh my
God that happened literally it's also
not the scariest thing to hit the detail
uh it ain't the scariest thing in the
MCU we got a lot more scary stuff coming
up and Jessica might or might not go in
on don't worry darling uh are you ready
to do it hey I have a full speech we'll
see we'll see we'll see I'm prepared but
it's coming and it's not hot because
everyone agrees with me I'm worried it's
a spicy take uh and we're gonna pick
some horror movies to y'all but enough
about that I'm Brandon Barrick and
across the way we got John Costa you
thought it was dead whoa geez don't
scream John I'm alive I'm just barely he
has risen he has really he has Rises
initials JC initials JC you can't kill
us
and I don't know who propagated it I
don't know who started it but it did
exist I think it was next to the
recently resurrected John Costa we got
Jessica Clemens another resurrected Soul
oh that's right she's back baby uh and
we had a great talking dragons this
morning make sure you check that out on
the channel if you haven't already and
right next to me we got the man Tommy B
it's Tommy bechtold hi everyone uh
obviously I'm in a little bit of a
Melancholy mood whoa uh most of you who
know me know that I'm a pretty big fan
of the Buffalo Bills oh about that last
night they sure yesterday afternoon they
strolled into Miami and
dominated them in every statistical
category except for the one that counts
the final score oh no to all my Miami
fans out there who are also huge
bechtold stands
be careful because we play again in
December
and remember I have access to all your
addresses oh my God how did you get
their address there's also too many
bills fan I feel but people are lying
there's no such thing as I feel like
people are alive I will say I will say
Tommy has a New York Jets tattoo on his
ass cheek I do so you don't even like
the bills
well it says New York Jets but when I
spread them it says New York jettisoned
all the way to California uh
hey thank you to all our super Chatters
out there already going crazy it's
Monday so we're doing Monday hot Monday
a hot Monday we want to motivate you on
this all right Monday to have a sexy
week sorry I don't know where that came
from uh for every hundred dollars we're
gonna take our clothes off no we are not
no we'll take a piece off I got a lot on
them uh we'll we'll spin the character
wheel we'll give you a Monday motivation
yeah as that character Thomas shows up
to strip poker like it's 42 degrees in
in Los Angeles
six jackets the thing is I just wear a
winter jacket I'm completely naked also
Tommy's already taken off a shirt once
yeah that's true we gotta cover the
nipples it was twice uh they're pulling
right now to see who's gonna give our
first Monday motivation we already got a
big super chat from Corey Kendra boy
Corey uh sending in 100 bucks saying
let's get it I've been gone too long yes
you have of course we're so glad to have
you back we also had a super chat right
as the show started from J rhymney Leah
right yeah so grateful for you nerds
your super duper poppers yeah hey
poppers uh and jota Suave wants John to
prove he's not a scroll tell us
something about yourself only the real
John Wood now
the real me died a decade ago oh my gosh
he's right so oh that's quite a paradox
if you are the real John how would you
know and the real John I resurrected
John 10 years ago that's my little
puppet thing it was a Sleeping Beauty
type of situation Tommy hey Tommy won
the poll so Tommy's gonna spin the wheel
the wheel's not there he's getting the
microphone get on my stick I thought he
was getting the sword give me an effing
money there are these Impressions yeah
you're gonna give a motivational speech
as this as this person okay great
you're familiar you're familiar with the
character all right let's get a
motivational speech from Tony Stark
listen up nerds uh for me life has been
very easy I'm very rich I didn't have a
good relationship with my father I loved
my mother but they were both murdered by
my best friends uh secret best friend
who we all assumed was dead yeah so what
today's speech is going to be about is
secrets and my secret secrets are no fun
secret Secrets hurt someone so if you're
holding on to a secret right now
something deep down in your heart that's
a lump of coal you think might turn into
a diamond because the pressure's getting
so thick let it on out confess it in the
chat and let your old Uncle tea bag
settle it up for you okay we'll read
them out loud super chats this week I
have
that ain't no secret man we've seen the
bathroom it's a graveyard in there you
want to talk about people coming back
from the dead there is no secret
everyone here has some real bowel issues
we're getting a gastroenterologist in
here to do some house calls everybody
have a great Monday that was beautiful
beautiful
he did come from my butt two days ago
that's why that's why the hemborgs are
there Jesus
you know what helps with hemorrhoids a
little Preparation H and by h i mean
headline hey the bomb that oh no it's so
nice that no one watches the show so we
can do whatever we want thank goodness
no one's watching all right Philip this
is gonna be the one Philip this one
bless bless bless up to you Phillip uh
James Earl Jones uh he he officially is
retired as the voice of Darth Vader he's
no longer going to lend his live voice
Darth Vader Darth Vader but uh we as we
know they kind of have this voice in AI
for now I would actually kill someone to
get our hands on the AI oh I mean the
sound box alone for making crank calls
would be incredible my James Aussie is
bursting uh no I think how do you think
do you think they were like uh that's my
favorite do you think they were like
Vayner or James do you want to play
Darth Vader anymore he went no
the contract was alive I felt it uh yeah
they have used his voice in shows
recently he's come in to do live audio
sessions I guess but they've also been
using his voice and I'm pretty sure
Kenobi was just manufactured because it
was so young so full of light I have
altered the terms of my deal pray I
don't oh here's my question do you think
they'll do so the new Lion King movie is
going to be a Mufasa origin story
they'll just cast someone else yeah I
think they will cast someone else even
though
uh even in in the uh
uh you know there's a a great little
channel YouTube channel out there called
your yourmoviesucks and they did a very
big uh in-depth look at that because
they they had said like oh we're
bringing Egyptians Jones he's doing new
stuff we barely used any old stuff but
they do use old clips from previous
recordings and some new James Earl Jones
and you could kind of tell he was
getting what is this Crystal Pepsi [ __ ]
this I want regular Pepsi the story of
you sharing that in the new exercise
slack is a story that we'll have to tell
on the great room after show that might
be happening at some point yeah we're
gonna do more of this we have to do work
itself if they subscribe Kelly no Kelly
Kelly yes now well she wants better
Kelly in the chat but also in the
building in the office
about to be on screen editor Kelly could
happen we'll make laser cards right
we'll make her spin the wheel all right
Kelly yeah you may have to give a
motivational speech which you just uh
you just got us into the next level
wait Kelly Kelly you can't no
Kelly you can't set a super cat
it's too late it already happened next
headline
and or season one has a high death toll
and you've been warned okay things are
about to get deadly on that show yeah it
doesn't die who
Cassie and Andrew we don't know they
could bring them back he could be a
robot he could have been a Droid the
whole time in Rogue one maybe he's a
clone door uh if you haven't watched I
like that one I am so sick
of everyone's I'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired oh my god
um yeah be disappointed if you haven't
watched the first two episodes of
Android yet they're really good they're
great and there's already a lot of death
in those first three episodes uh but the
director of this show and the creator of
attorney Gilroy who said that the body
count is going to be really high all the
way through uh there are people that
live Cassie and Andor Saul Guerrera
makes it at least the Linux movie uh uh
but he points out that this is a time
that's a revolution it's a very intense
period of time people are doing very
dangerous things some people live and
some people don't how do we know who
lives and dies at the end from the
previous Star Wars you wouldn't know and
he also says I mean there's people
buried in Yavin who knows who there
who's there now that's true the people
buried on Japanese we're just hanging
out on the base and died of natural
causes I don't remember attack happening
on Yavin for they're flying over it but
they don't ever blow up the planet or
anything or send down ships as far as I
know maybe no what is this okay giveaway
know that I don't know what if he just
outed himself in this Lincoln episode
that's coming in later and he's like
it's gonna be Leia lining up people and
you're having fun
right I heard that this is
I heard a roommate Tony Gilroy went to
the doctor and when they did an x-ray on
them they found out he got that dog oh
no oh no he got that dog
uh hey Jessica yeah
yeah we want to hear from you about
don't worry darling but but first okay
would you motivate us please oh do you
want to make counties for a little while
Kelly you want to spin the wheel
she's coming you don't have to say
anything you're not allowed to say
anything yeah
well you can talk before you get into
the room
oh wow
this is our editor Kelly she's in the
building she has to say anything say it
into this mic don't make her get so
close
hello hi I I should have thought of
something to say I didn't that's all
right we never did
a lot of early jokes for a big question
that was like my next day because I did
a lot of those jokes for big questions
big head gang she's a great co-creator
head gang at the start when that became
a thing so yeah
yeah let it go there you go
believe in yourself
it has to go around family or Price is
Right rules yeah yeah
[Applause]
hello there
um oh this is like Posh Spice
it falls mainly on the plane there you
go all right
um look here
if I was you yeah yeah you I don't okay
no I'm doing great
um
put yourself out there
uh go flaunt what you have all your bits
and your jits uh your gibbles and your
gobbles go out there and shake it like
your mother didn't break it to make it
um what I'm saying is strip for money
and what I'm saying is
earn what you would deserve and I can't
speak in a British accent unless I'm
making fun of someone
um this was a very bad motivation okay
nope
oh you're picking you're just gonna pick
one hey oh my British friends
you put these on Kingpin okay I can do
Kingpin oh nice Spider-Man if I'm making
an omelette best believe it's egg whites
[Laughter]
if you want to own the city like me
think about it for a second
do you deserve it maybe you do maybe you
don't but
it's motivation take control of your
city they might call it bad things but
you weren't just trying to make the
neighborhood better we just want to
bring greatness to our neighborhood so
go ahead go into your neighborhood make
an art museum and buy the first painting
you see put it on the wall and then sell
it for triple the price trust me art is
a scam and you can do it
beautiful Val Kilmer from Top Gun
Maverick I thought I thought I had a
little bit I like the head thing she did
yeah Jesse
Americans always turn to Aussie when
they try to do British nor we darn no no
I never said I could do it I don't I did
put one character on there that I could
do and then I was like oh hopefully
Tommy gets Peggy Carter and then there
you go there you have him talk to us
about that don't worry Destiny yeah
um oh don't worry darling yeah tell us
about it so without spoilers because I
think I'm the only person here that's
saying it yes so without spoilers you
guys I will say what you're hearing in
the Press completely valid and true
um I am someone that has done acting not
as heavily as a lot of people have but
from watching it I can tell that even
Florence Pugh Academy Award nominated
actress is so lost in the film and very
confused and a lot of the direction that
she gave Harry Styles Olivia Wilde is
poorly misjudged they should have never
done what they did I'll give you one
take uh for the first half of the movie
you think he's trying to do a normal
West Coast accent he's just doing a
normal American accent and then someone
calls him a Brit and we realize that
what was the accent we I don't know what
the voice is uh the movie was
directionally bad though artistically
pleasing it was absolutely what I wanted
in art and heavy and costume and
wardrobe so good but I just think Olivia
Wilde directing uh directing
book smart book smart is a lot different
than her direct day in a film about a
bunch of adults and in whatever they're
doing does that make sense books marks a
bunch of teenagers in his party and it's
a lot you can do improv you can go let
loose this is a drama it's not a comedy
so it doesn't hit as well and also
um
when you watch the movie you'll be like
oh this is exactly like another movie I
saw oh just with white people
interesting interesting book smart what
a thing
but it's actually the line
an inside scoop about don't worry
darling I think was sort of in the
trades but okay here's a text I got the
other day I have don't worry darling
insert info from one of the actors in
the movie Timothy Simmons just kidding
apparently Florence and Olivia never
liked each other and Olivia rarely was
actually on set she would leave set to
go into Harry's trailer for hours and
the DP actually directed the movie which
is why Florence is pissed about the
whole thing so really Jessica
hates the Director of Photography and
they're bad oh no well no because he's
not supposed to be directing Olivia
Wilde was supposed to direct well and I
have
no you can feel in the movie you're like
oh they're not enjoying talking here's
my question for you does it feel like a
movie
what does that mean what
[Music]
no one no no one's seen that interview
all right moving on uh oh yes thank you
I get what you're saying now I guess
what we should be saying is the studio
better
worry darling okay beautiful beautiful
and that and the show was the break room
discusses don't worry darling uh thank
you for back to Barbie watch this week
uh our next headline uh where will
finite was updated on the Disney plus
genre breakdown from Comedy to horror
that's right horror uh it recently
showed that fantastic Fest this last
weekend was it this last weekend uh and
some screeners went out and we got some
initial responses from people their
initial takes that we could show a few
of these uh well by night is the 70s
Horrors comic through the 1930s oh let's
see Robert that is sorry Robert Garfield
he wrote he wrote black phone he's a
great writer he's phenomenal and he
follows me on Twitter oh there you go a
little old little Flex there a true
spooky October treat a lot of fun I
think we have another one
maybe oh yeah uh the Marvel didn't know
the map quality wise but were off by
night is easily the best thing we've
done yes even better than Moon Knight
which you know I loved whoa are there
any more yeah
this Joker
generally scary at times and dipping
with Macabre camp Oh what a what a word
violent Delights a little Westworld we
didn't even read it we just judged him
the weird there's like two things that
stood out for me uh about all these
reactions it was two two things uh the
uh violence and like horish you know
that kind of thing is like more than
Marvel has ever really done which is
kind of cool and interesting and unique
they're putting it on a different
platform they don't have to put it in
theaters so they can it seems like they
can really go wild and then everyone is
saying like the standout character from
this is man thing and like everyone is
gonna be in love with hi hi I'm all
right it looks like by all accounts
werewolf by night
is gonna be all right
I hate it here worry darling very
darling it does look it does look really
good I'm very excited for it he's been
the trailer that they put
that there is a lot of like blood even
though it's like black it's gonna be all
right oh God don't encourage
uh there's a lot of blood in the trailer
but it's black and white so it's like
they can kind of like show it but like
we you don't see blood a lot in the MCU
did they film that movie back in time or
is this current day but they make it
look nice if you use cameras from the
1930s okay I don't still don't
understand how any of that works I just
assume they're all old footage we found
now if you use the camera is incapable
of doing color it's fine okay uh the
executive producer of werewolf by night
has confirmed that more monsters are
coming to the MCU this has kind of been
the big question with this show is like
how far away from it is it from the real
MCU is it like in a different universe
is it in a pocket Dimension how is it
connected but he said uh I think one
very cool things about the special is
just peeling back the corner of monsters
in the MCU so there's not just the
monsters that are part of werewolf by
night but the ones that were up on the
wall there's some of that artwork work
as well so I think things we're going to
see in this show could pop up later in
the MCU we don't exactly know where
they'll pop up next he said the idea is
that with this wide swath of different
species and types they're going to pop
up again you're going to see these guys
in different ways of course now everyone
knows that Michael Jubilee was made into
a vampire in the comedy all right this
is the only way he's right yeah
wait wait he changed the subject first
I'm gonna change a second then you go
back to what our topic was one you guys
in the chat I know he also co-wrote the
first Doctor Strange movie but the most
recent movie that he did was I'm going
back to the Tweet where I was like the
first movie you did was black or the
last movie you did was black phone this
is C Robert Cargill it's C Robert cargo
joined by Scott Dirksen who also
directed the first time you don't
mention everyone's credits I'm not an
IMDb I just brought up black phone
because I was the one that did press it
is this Scott Derrickson making like a
vampire movie Blackfoot was that a
vampire blade
that it was either MCU Canon or like
Canon or Jason it could be Canon later
you know if it's right or something like
that I don't know what that is
um but you know like the like the I mean
I hate to compare things to the Star
Wars holiday special but like that that
yeah like things from that holiday
special have become Canon throughout
time so I wouldn't be surprised if
they're like it's not necessarily Canon
and then later on they're like you know
we're gonna take this screen that movie
first interview introduced like a little
bit of a going into a a headset theater
experience and seeing a kind of an
erotic film and I'm told now with these
oculuses you can do the same thing I
would never know pornography I can't
have internet connection legally at my
house because trading ideas one day
without Tommy bringing up his plans for
some fully pornographic VR studio in his
house
I would be grateful oh okay next
headline Tom Hiddleston says that season
two of Loki is quote largely focused on
a battle for the soul of the TVA oh oh
apparently he cares about the team well
I guess I love you now he just loves
Sylvie it's all about Silver Fall do
they need to fall do you need because it
doesn't seem like they're keeping they
do unfortunately keep things in order so
it's like are they just looking for
another person to replace King yeah I
guess my question is what is the soul of
the TVA what is that Soul well order
well that's yes I agree with you because
it's like that is the big question
because it's also yes Donahue
no but uh what I was gonna say was that
um yeah are they gonna get rid of the
whole idea of like oh this person made a
big disturbance we're gonna throw them
in a different timeline that's like
Barren well and what we know of the TVA
is what he who remains had made of the
TV yeah and that point of that TVA was
to keep that timeline separated from all
the others to keep it isolated and away
from all the other kings and all the
other timelines so the pruning he was
doing when not was not necessarily done
in an effort to preserve time or to keep
the universe happy it was to keep Kang
out at all costs so there was so yeah
that's the decisions he's making aren't
necessarily what's right for time or
what's right for Humanity or life he was
just kind of being a selfish prick it
was like I don't want to deal with
myself right exactly so
the best way to win the game is to not
play at all we learn in that for more
games right that's the only way to win
Donahue come on board games
law Chuck said the soul of the TVA is
clearly Casey is that could that be true
uh up to a series regular that's right
last week
about it well and I do think some of
what we touched on last week uh is that
the idea that the people who are in the
TVA maybe it's about getting them back
to where they belong right but they're
all variants so I don't know they're
they're they're primes
of sexy
and someone else remembered my
that missed minutes might be a Kang or
something no I was saying if you're
gonna if you're into cartoon erotica
Google cogsworth destroys Smith Jesus
Christ reference number two to your
Oculus
I don't have an Oculus I think they have
a thing that takes my eyeballs out
you got the you got the Batman
fixing what her gears oh he's fixing her
gears uh I yeah it is an interesting
problem this is an interesting quote
from Tom Henderson we're so excited for
a Loki season two we really hope you saw
a trailer yeah we really hope that
trailer comes out soon they should be
dropping a lot of trailers as we end the
year I don't I don't know we'll see
we'll see next headline James Gunn has
been teasing more about the uh Gardens
of the Galaxy holiday special he likes
to go off on Twitter and I go off on
Twitter likes to respond to his fans on
Twitter uh when they have questions uh
he was saying that the Guardians holiday
special is quote an epilogue to phase
four he also says uh it's the connective
plot elements between endgame and volume
three uh do you think he just hates Thor
love and thunder yeah he's like we're
not I'm not gonna address it he's like
I'm the funny he didn't say this is the
only connective elements he said it's
part of that uh also you know that's
right they were looking for Gamora I'm
so sorry they were looking for Gamora at
the end of that film and they didn't
address any of that in Thor yeah I was
gonna say I like the idea that he is
feuding with before only because uh we
know that taikwatichi was like I only
put the goats in there because James
yeah yeah yeah and I told you my theory
that the opening shot of Guardians of
the Galaxy should be them roasting two
giant goats over the tires being like
goat meat is so tender
um he also said that even though the
holiday special is a standalone it
contains a lot of new facts about the
guardian's characters and what they've
been up to all these years all these
years was a really weird one it's been a
while
between end game and
um
don't read the chat right now between
in-game and where they get in uh in
volume three yeah
it has been a while well and even from
in-game to where we're at right now it's
been like a couple of years yeah yeah
and we don't know we don't know when
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is going
to take place because it's sort of mid
phase five yeah uh and phase four was
what like two two three years so that
could be five years and they they were
always kind of out of time even when
those two films came out previously
that's very true they sit really close
to each other on the timeline and I
think uh James Gunn previously had said
like oh I didn't realize that uh
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 was a
phase five film it's just like it's the
third Guardians of the Galaxy movie more
than it is the third phase five for sure
whatever guys we're so close to another
motivational speech and I think after
you've seen the first year
pretty Dynamic today so let's try and
get up to the third one at least my
family
speaking of British accents I was in
Europe uh this I was in Europe that's
why I was gone last week five minutes
my point is my point is I was I was just
recently on a plane for like 13 hours
and it was exhausting and I didn't have
a lot to do
um I was trying to watch football but
this internet on the plane was not very
good they deprived you of watching your
first Jets Victory well in sort of the
Jackson thing
um they lost uh oh the week before yeah
yeah but but uh one thing that I did do
on the plane was some
very brain stimulating oh boy uh mobile
games that's all I had that's all I had
I was desperate I was desperate and hey
look if you're looking for a match three
game to play that's one of those things
where you got a bunch of things you try
to match three and then they go away and
then it fills them swiping and you're
like yeah uh you can try Disney's Emoji
Disney Emoji Blitz which you know I
don't know if you're familiar with
Disney
um but they have a lot of cool
properties so someone's sharing your
Disney Plus account you're watching the
Marvel and the Star Wars and someone
else is watching the frozens and uh
Jeff goldblue he presents I love Nat Geo
talking Geo uh it's unlike any other
match three game on the market because
each Emoji has its own unique power up
and those little emojis are some of your
favorite Disney characters
um there's a ton of emojis to choose
from whether uh with deep collection of
Disney Pixar Star Wars IP and new
characters that they add every week and
every month you can download the Disney
Emoji Blitz
app using our link Jam City dot me slash
Emoji rockstars say it again Jam City
dot me
slash Emoji rockstars okay quick quick
question do it on the train when you're
going to work do it uh on the plane when
you're coming home from Europe I have a
question about the game because
yesterday I was playing and I was
frantically trying to put a grandfather
clock uh
and a Candlestick together
smash the pocket watch yes your phone
bro
no no there's nothing about the game but
the grandfather clock and the
Candlestick we're just going under the
pocket watch to the broken half that
wasn't Emoji Blitz no that wasn't Emoji
Blitz no no no that was just trying to
text my my therapist what had happened I
got my mandatory fun mug and the antique
Morphin it's already an antique it isn't
it it is I think you're too you're so
ashamed you're not even showing it on
camera somebody told me The Morbid mugs
are going on eBay for it not thing oh oh
wow
oh wow we did just get a new shipment of
mandatory fun books into the office so
it was sad to crack those open and see
Neary that's more of a Time Michael
Morgan inside but you know what we did
see what do we see Empire released some
new images uh with a a cover of black
panther wakanda forever with their
exclusive take a look here
um some of the titular characters uh
perhaps uh from Black Panther are you
saying one of those is Black Panther
um uh for black panther what kind of
forever but there's also a bunch of
other new images and some really cool
um there's one of Neymar's cool
headpiece that has sort of a collage of
uh different images that inspired the
film uh I don't know what's going on
over here he's reading the chat
um um that they said they worked with
the production designer on the film to
create that collage which is really neat
um
I want to read some of the great
interview uh uh pieces that came out of
the film uh came out of the magazine
article before we get into our main
discussion let's do it they interviewed
everyone from uh the director to Kevin
feige to the cast and and here's some of
the interesting things they had to say
um this was Leticia Wright saying uh
when sort of asked about her potentially
taking on the mantle of black panther
she said I had a chat about it with Ryan
and Chad when we were making Black
Panther and we touched on it briefly uh
she said when I realized I was playing
shuri it was something that I really
looked forward to because that's
something the character gets to do in
the comics so that sort of fueled a
little speculation over you know whether
she could be one of the people uh or the
person uh taking on that role in this
film
uh let's see Ryan coogler also said uh
he had already sort of had his idea of
what this film was going to be before uh
Chadwick passed away he said uh he had
an additional an initial sequel idea
involving t'challa one thing he said was
spiritually very similar to wakanda
Forever before uh Chadwick Boseman uh
who passed away in August of 2020. uh
and that to me sort of says like hey and
we're going to get into this in a second
you you know uh
the they probably took the t'challa
character out did a lot with the theme
of grief and loss but kept in the main
plot of Atlantis in in this case uh
tolokin and Namor and the whole fight
over vibranium and all that kind of
thing that we think this movie is
probably going to be about
um yeah yeah Kevin feigue is also
talking about the prospects of recasting
t'challa and he said this he said Stan
Lee always said that Marvel represents
the world outside your window and we had
talked about how uh as our as
extraordinary and Fantastical as our
characters and stories are there's
relatable and human element to
everything that we do the world is still
processing the loss of Chad and Ryan
poured that into the story so it sounds
like from Marvel's point of view they
wanted to be honest with their own
emotions about sort of losing a friend
and pour off that feeling into this
movie instead of trying to like you know
either pretend that it wasn't something
that they were feeling or moving on in a
way that that they didn't like and I
like this sort of Stan Lee quote because
because
Marvel has always throughout its history
in the comics like
you know held up a lens to success
society and said like hey these are some
of the issues that we're facing uh
whether that be you know mutants being
an allegory for racism or you know that
famous Captain America issue where he's
punching Hitler and all that kind of
stuff you know this is an opportunity
for Marvel to say like hey we feel this
big loss in the world and we want to
share how we feel with with you guys um
so I thought that was really neat and
then uh some of them some of the little
morsels that will lead us to today's
kind of question
um uh to not cuerto who's playing Namor
said that Neymar is indeed playing a
mutant in this film obviously Neymar
mutant in the comics uh the first mutant
you could kind of say uh in Marvel
Comics
um but the second mutant in the MCU
what's happening something that fell
from the ceiling oh my God it could have
been more confetti I think it was wet
um and this was the most interesting
thing he said uh that Namor is drawn to
the surface by the ramifications of
t'challa's decision in Black Panther's
final reel to reveal the truth of
wakanda to the world he says that
decision puts tolokin in Jeopardy and
tolokin has to take action to protect
themselves so we had sort of been
speculating for a long time that it's
possible that uh Neymar was like hey you
just told the world about this like
secret location now people are looking
for other secret countries which really
puts us at stake uh that's not cool
um and uh what do you got what do you
guys think you know
Namor we we have this really interesting
image of uh ramonda and shuri uh that
Brandon and I were talking about earlier
today and they're like weirdly wearing
they're like wearing weird clothes right
like more Super Cash can you leave that
image up for a little while
like
never not in a head Ramona doesn't have
her headdress on Sheree looks like she
like stole some construction workers
outfit uh somebody like the wigs that
they put on
um but this sort of got us speculating
we also thought that the background
there I mean it does kind of look like
some of the stuff we saw in the opening
scene it looks like like that kind of
coastal area we see in these trailers a
lot but also we're like that which I
don't know if that's like the under
water stuff in to Logan if they're if
they're doing the bubble thing I don't
know how they're going to represent
right like in the comics Atlantis like
physically has a block yeah uh and then
there's other parts of it where there's
like people who actually breed the water
but like this looks like they're gonna
have some coastal areas that are
involved with it somehow yeah well I
think what's most interesting is from
the scene descriptions that we got from
the d23 footage it does look like this
movie is going to have like a lot of
political elements to it Rhonda in the
U.N and bringing all this sort of like
vibranium people in uh and and we were
talking earlier like it would make sense
to us if that image there was
representing uh Ramona and shuri trying
to escape from uh to Loken right right
and if Neymar had sort of captured them
as political prisoners somehow and that
was something that they had to deal with
and you know wakanda's response to not
only the loss of their black panther but
also their Queen and their princess and
like what that would do to that Nation
um so I don't know what do you guys
think will will be the main source of
conflict how do you think these
characters are going to get together do
you think it's just Neymar's gonna just
rock up to the beach and be like hey and
kidnap him you know well I mean I think
it could be the Revelation that wakanda
had this crazy high-tech society and all
the in the Vibra and the basically the
world's biggest stock vibranium may have
led other world leaders to start looking
for other cloak societies existing off
of the grid so to speak so I have a
feeling there'll probably be some sort
of like human-led Mission by some sort
of human military installation that
interrupts the toloken right the the
telokan people in some now ends up
killing some innocent to Logan civilians
thus pissing off Neymar and sending
Neymar uh rather than coming at the
entire world taking out one by one
starting with the wakandans do you think
that anyone that we with that theory
which I love uh who who dies
uh uh who you know
you're not gonna kill off Neymar in this
movie could they kill him Baku could
they kill him Baku I mean I would be I
don't want him to I think they could but
there's no point to killing him I feel
like he wouldn't be as connected as you
would if it was Angela Bassett yeah I
know but they feel the whole thing I
know it would be rough to lose anyone
else
I don't know I mean I think these are
real people right no they're not they're
fiction characters I think uh you know I
we've kind of joked around or talked
about like Neymar looking like the big
bad in this but in the end they're
fighting together against some other
force or something like that uh I think
that's gonna play a lot into it you
bring up the political stuff you know
you uh um they they show what kind of
everybody they're like hey we're here
this is our technology welcome uh and
then like end game happens right and the
snap happens and it changes everything
Infinity War happens in Canada right
that happens there so I don't know if
there's any amount of blame they're
trying to throw on what kind of problems
this is your fault he's like just give
us
like to look and son and then all of a
sudden the sun just dusts but it's in
the water so it just smudgies
well speaking of secret societies yeah
one uh one location we have not heard
mentioned in the MCU yet is
yeah right there's all these rumors that
do might come into this movie somehow or
some shape some way I don't like the
idea if if Namor and wakanda were to
team up somehow I wouldn't like it to be
like against some sort of like
government Army that seems too faceless
it seems a little
it would be like okay now you have two
people coming together and they have to
fight like people that we don't
necessarily care about but if you put a
face to that group of people and that
face was masked and didn't have a face
um that could be a really interesting
way of bringing Doom into this story
um I don't know if they would do
something so big with that character so
early I think they want to keep Namor to
be the antagonist yeah I I wouldn't be
surprised if that is how we get Doom in
the MCU right everyone there's a lot of
Buzz around like oh Doom's gonna have
some sort of appearance in this movie or
play some Rob post credit scene or
something like that I still like my idea
you're kind of alluding to this that if
wakanda reveals itself and then like uh
talokin feels like well okay well we're
here to all of them come in at once like
Blackberry is like yes we're here and
then like there's like some weird I mean
we've seen scenes at the U.N it would be
it wouldn't be incredible if like you
know you got all the countries and all
the flags and they're like raising new
Flags
but we all know Duke's coming in
whenever K Ross reveals himself to be
doom and I think we can end it right oh
I hate that but I also think it'd be
really fun I think it'd be amazing yeah
because everyone wants to cast like the
most handsome man on Earth to play
Doctor Doom and if it's just Martin
Freeman's a good looking guy but he's
he's Bilbo Baggins like he's cute he's a
little kitty I'm doomed now you're wrong
well if you don't want your health to be
doctor doomed maybe check out our
sponsor today athletic greens uh I'm
actually a big fan of their product ag1
uh I'm not good at being healthy I'm bad
at it I'm not good at routines I I drop
them immediately like like my health uh
but ag1 makes it so easy to get all of
my daily nutrition in one easy and tasty
drink I think it tastes good I like the
taste of it uh with one delicious scoop
of ag1 you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Foods store
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
and aging folks I was born in 2002 but
I'm so afraid of of growing any older
than I already am
how old are you by the way if I was born
yeah
I'm almost 21 years old yeah you try to
get in the bar with me the other weekend
I didn't want to he followed me home I
do ag1 it does so much for you folks uh
include it supports like a better sleep
quality and Recovery I feel like I've
been sleeping better since I started
drinking every day plus it also supports
mental Clarity and alertness with my 20
year old brain I want to keep that as
sharp as possible yeah with ag1 you're
getting an all-in-one nutritional
insurance it's much cheaper than
sourcing all the healthy ingredients
yourself you tell me you're going to go
to the store and you're going to buy
niacin folates actually that's vitamin C
you want to buy all this stuff this is a
long list I made a big bowl of folates
last night and I'm all full up on it
it's all full up on folates I've always
been full full that's expensive don't do
that check this out ag1 is a small micro
habit with big benefits it's the one
thing you can do every single day to
take care of yourself and for every
purchase they donate to organizations
helping to get nutritious foods and need
to kids in need including no kid hungry
right here in the US so reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition it's just one
scoop and a cup of water every day
that's it to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you yes you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin D and five free
travel packs to go with your first
purchase that's a real wow moment right
there
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com break room again
that's a athletic greens.com break room
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance the president said there is no
way you were born in 2002 how dare you
how dare you
look at that young baby boy
bro I can't even grow facial hair
everybody knows we're offered when it
comes to what you're about to do we do
oh that's what I'm getting I've got it
all built in don't worry guys
predatory 5K please why'd you let Johnny
do this please listen to me Tommy's got
it the segment that's been so delayed we
just got to get that graphic played
again
yes it's Monday you know what that means
it's time for me to get three of my
absolute best friends in the whole wide
world together for a little bit of fun
that they can't say no to which sounds
problematic but it's just a segment on
the show now I can't be here today
I got a call from Dr Ashley you had a
call from Dr nasty last week I got a
call from Dr nasty this week Dr nasty
called me and he let me know that the
panda bear cheeks that I'm getting
implanted you know I'm sensitive about
my butt Oh I thought these are face
changing no no no I'm actually getting
panda bear face cheeks okay grafted to
my ass
uh for what's going to be called a
pandas uh so anyway Dr nasty is going to
get that done I uh did find someone to
come in and do mandatory fun today but
well I'm getting him ready I think
Brandon could do his motivational speech
yes yes
they have to give it back I will give it
back okay
it was Mark Simpson the one you can do
yeah I knew it there's Donnie on there
Donny Osmond who's dummy Donnie from the
wild foreign
delicious they're in the break room here
you go this is your Monday motivation
from Chewbacca M Peterson
blah okay
[Music]
I'm trying
and how would you put how would you put
it in the jar
it's not that complicated
silence oh
yes he's got glasses get his eye oh oh
studious he's got a nice thing Michael
back told the glasses were a distraction
Hollywood bond be pumped
trainer to the Stars father of a bird
and a boy
and a couple of other children as well
and I'm here to host mandatory fun today
werewolf by Knight introducing horror
elements to the MCU has got us all bug
[ __ ] crazy oh
so my people came to me and they said
Okay Michael
get your nose off of that porcelain
toilet get out of the bathroom sober up
and start working on our next film we
want you to make a spooky spooky spooky
cinematic experience
and I said you found just the man to do
it
just the man to do it so
I've asked all three of you okay oh to
have the opportunity oh to audition for
my film today oh what if we don't want
it I will be announcing the name of my
film now oh T Michael bechtold Studios
presents a Marvel Studios event produced
by Kevin feige and Marvel Studios
not necessarily affiliated with t
Michael Bechtel studios in arcade master
of chance lover of Dance
now
I'd like to cast my titular character
arcade oh he loves that word with a
young titulation named Brandon Barrett
oh congratulations
no no we don't know we don't know okay
Jesus all right these roads look not
given oh yeah
um
auditioning for the role of Dr Lorena
Dobson AKA White Rabbit
movie Jessica Clemens congratulations
are they sending to share the role
auditioning for the role booked it
these aren't Dharma glasses
glasses you hear me
I wore them first
I was hanging out with Alan Arkin and
Warren Beatty in the Chateau my mark now
that's a reference
let's give it to Michael Dom Vibes Nina
be careful it's Perseus think of the
glasses what do you think
I did release
a copy of this script and a screener
of some a screener
screener of some board work that I had
done in peripheral see Robert Gilroy
said
when he read it
ah anyway I forgot what character I am
already you'll be reading the role of Dr
Thompson you'll be reading the role of
arcade arcade of course the famous
Marvel villain uh who created murder
world where he transfer you have your
own audition separately okay putting you
on the casting couch tonight my boy can
I ask a question yeah sure um Alex said
what were wired magazines thoughts
though Wired Magazine said oh no
on the toilet
word magazines I don't know geeked
magazine said oh brother
all right okay I'll repeat
do we have the image of Geek Magazine
that we pulled up we don't have it okay
you're showing thirsty oh yes all right
man great I will read the uh I will read
the descriptions okay interior night a
laboratory Dr Dobson finds herself in a
dark scary laboratory a light flickers
in the corner revealing a Madman sitting
crisscross applesauce a huge grin creeps
across his face this
is arcade
dear Dr Thompson
wait right here
oh my gosh I guess I'm already not
getting the part okay I told you no
building a robot version of Steve Rogers
is an insane idea exactly oh can I stop
you there
in my mind arcade
all right let's keep it going let's go
from there we don't need to go back
crap
I'll take your bag can you feed him now
you know Billy the robot version of
Steve Rogers is an insane idea exotic
exactly oh that's perfect but if I don't
help you you kill my family exactly
if I promise to help you will you
promise to kill them and make it painful
except wait what this is good I'm tired
of this life of luxury I want to take
risks I want to be free I want to be
White Rabbit Dr Dobson pulls out a pair
of bunny ears and puts them on her head
her evil smile now matches arcades oh
finally someone who knows how to heavily
Sue phone around here I'll send your
whole family to my new world but whether
they die or not is up to them thus is
the nature of my whole personality
so you are like the saw guy no no what
now he makes games I created Murder
World he's playing little league I'm
throwing 99 mile an hour murder
fastballs and I assume a cricket game
because I don't understand American bass
he's improvising I like when my actors
play with the script okay sorry okay G
sorry let's just build this robot and
kidnap my family please wonderful
wonderful give me the sides back you
both signed your ndas no validation get
out get out get out I like him that's a
winner that's an Oscar one okay now we
have another roll oh John you didn't
think I was gonna let you out of here
no no no John Perseus and I wrote this
this part just for you ourselves late
one night in our ghoulish laboratory
next to the McDonald's on Vine near
where the old Ark like Cinema you sure
yeah
[Laughter]
our character this is a character we
call Ron Gloucester Ron Gloucester is a
sad man with nothing to live for who's
been kidnapped by a shadowy figure
Ron Gloucester sits tied to a chair
terrified for his life
oh no
if I pooped and peed myself oh gross
would you like to play a game
you mean like the Saw movies no why does
everyone keep saying that I mean what's
the most you've ever lost in a coin talk
oh like uh like uh No Country for Old
Men God damn it no this is a simple game
you win or you die like Game of Thrones
yes shadowy figure swings a giant sword
and cuts Ron's head off you've got the
part John Costner I'm Peter and pooped
myself for this role
oh I've got to go okay I'm having
cryogenic therapy with Kelly Ripa right
next to Dantanna's on Melrose oh okay
well thank you so right next to our
offices see Michael back dog uh thanks
to our super Chatters today but you
should read the super checks
uh okay I'll read the super chats uh I
don't know if we got to this but sorry
for the Buffalo Bills lost in my name
Emmy Dolphins I'm not but not to be
worried my Seahawks loss is uh lost a
second game in a row this is slowly
becoming new mind if I stand by how's
your touch are a little tender they ran
out of panda touches so they just gave
me this guy named pandas I pooped and
peed myself so if you need the diaper
I've been using for you know Kush it's
so funny I actually picked up a magazine
that was reviewing a movie called arcade
master of chance oh yeah lover of dance
they were reviewing a movie that hasn't
been shot yet oh
this was People magazine and they said
ghosts
[Laughter]
uh Quentin said got my mandatory fun mug
and uh we already read that one but I
did see that film juice said my
mandatory fun mug is leaking now here's
the thing not a surprise here's the
thing film juice what not a surprise you
think these things leak the mandatory
fun mod yeah Oh I thought he might as
more but yeah that's the thing he's you
got you got beef with Zach
you're the squirrel wow maybe he also
hates Tommy JH also standing in a Super
Chat Hulk is a mutant the gamma unlocks
his Gene
Wolverine is also excited to sign up for
Tommy's VR fantasies oh yeah they're
under my website the daytime it gets the
ability to make VR games oh we're
already in production over there www dot
Tommy's Tunes
.ca now it's advice we did say today was
the day we were going to start talking
about Andor and more spoiler depths
um
it's a really good show we're all
enjoying it we did some uh Fantasy last
week yeah we'll do some updates on that
oh don't you worry I'm gonna tell
everybody their scores we got uh uh
She-Hulk fantasy league we gotta get up
to date this week and get ready for the
next episode of that show so much going
on in Earnest we also wanted to talk
about the trailer for The Last of Us
that came out today we're gonna do a
whole thing on it we're out of time yeah
maybe we'll talk about that tomorrow we
might break it down on the channel let
us know if that's something you want to
see we'll break it down on the talk
maybe we'll break some Tick Tock uh but
thank you all for joining us today on
this crazy Monday that we're really kept
under control and I feel great about it
it did not go off the ground it did not
go off on the rails I'm sweating
make sure to join our Discord where you
can submit uh your break room clip of
the week you can do exclamation point
Clips in the chat to learn more about
how to do that uh join us every day this
week right here same time same channel
uh we'll be live from our very own break
room here at our new Rockstar studios in
uh in the Ikea in the Ikea inside of
Wisconsin Madison Wisconsin uh we'll see
you all here tomorrow and we'll
definitely talk about Android I
guarantee it uh we hope you have a great
rest of your Monday we'll see you next
time